dana carvey you know dana corey is one
of the great impressionists
ever basically and a really funny
comedian and he's he was on snl
dana carvey who at least in his public
life
seems to lean left you know he was
always very nice about
obama and his you know he's had a lot of
mainstream success
dana just did a bit on his podcast
mocking this very fact mocking the
arbitrariness
of the power of the established regime
mocking how little the the this
establishment is accountable to the
people
and how little they care what the people
think he he mocked it in the person of
one tony fauci but if
it's proven the virus escaped from a lab
i'll have no regrets but if i have my
brothers i hope the whole world
forgets i'm
tony fauci
[Applause]
and from the bottom of my heart
[Music]
go
go [ __ ] yourself we'll be right back
with kelsey grandma
so the whole the whole bit is that tony
fauci is this kind of like
crooner like a late night host so he's
doing him kind of as a sinatra
or a dean martin i will say you know
dana carvey has
some of the greatest impressions ever
the tony fauci
i don't know the voice is not quite i
think the character is there the voice i
don't know i don't know i'm just saying
some other people do impressions and you
know one can judge for oneself
the point he's making though is totally
right i'm tony fauci
and you can go f yourself that's what i
care about you you stupid peasants
i'm tony fauci he doesn't obviously he's
not accountable and he is just
he's a real person but he's a symbol of
that that broader
administrative state the public health
bureaucracy that just doesn't care you
can complain and we can talk until we're
blue in the face
but they've got the political power and
we don't
if you do not ring that bell subscribe
to this
video then youtube will render me
speechless which is coincidentally the
name of my upcoming book it's going to
be released in 11 days speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which is available now for pre-order
you got to get those notifications you
got to make sure you don't miss a video
and head on over to apple podcast google
play stitcher spotify
gmail hotmail aol instant messenger
subscribe to the michael knowles show
audio podcast leave a five star review
see you next time